by now I think we've established that
software engineers at Fan companies are
paid a boatload of money this is usually
anywhere between 175 000 per year to as
much as a 1.82 million dollars per year
while it's extraordinarily difficult to
get to level seven or eight and earn 7
figure salaries and it's relatively
possible to get the level 5 or 6 if you
make the correct education and career
choices and are willing to grind out
lead code but all of this comes with the
one caveat you have to go into software
engineering from an objective
perspective this Choice seems like a
no-brainer but not everyone is good at
software engineering and even if they
are they don't necessarily want to serve
stack Overflow all day they'd much
rather talk with customers and
colleagues set business goals and the
drive forward the company fortunately
while software Engineers do get the
highest salaries there are several roles
at these companies that pay nearly as
much with no coding experience so here's
the top three highest paying paying jobs
that don't require coding
starting off with one of the broadest
jobs offered at fanga we have a product
managers product managers are
responsible for setting the goals and
division of a given product and
coordinating the right people for
example if you were the product manager
of Instagram your first goal would be to
define the needs of Instagram users for
Instagram this would probably be hours
of mindless entertainment along with
social validation the Second Step would
be to create different Pathways in which
your product can achieve these goals one
pathway might be to leverage photos
while another would be to leverage short
form video once you've got a couple of
strong plans your job would be to
convince senior leadership that they
should actually put resources Behind
these plans and make them a reality if
all goes well you'll have to work with
the technical people to make sure that
your vision is actually executed
correctly and in the end your
performance will be evaluated based on
how well you achieve the needs of your
customers and stakeholders for example
how much did your idea increase user
engagement and how much did it increase
user satisfaction similarly how cost
effective was it and was there better
options as you can see it there's
nothing that's technically Difficult
about this role but that's also what
makes this job so difficult you're often
working with abstract Concepts and
divisions to produce quantifiable
results on the bright side while the
title has the word manager in it you
won't have any direct reports unless
you're at an extremely senior level this
means that you can be hired into this
role straight out of college as an L3
product manager and most of the people
at this level are indeed fresh college
graduates you definitely won't be
working on something as influential as
Instagram or YouTube at this level but
you may get to work on certain
subproducts of these systems for example
you may be in charge of Instagram's news
feed or YouTube's like button in terms
of career trajectory you have the
potential of reaching seven figures as a
product director so there's plenty of
room to grow up also most c-suite
Executives were product managers and at
one point in their careers including
Sundar piche so if you're aiming for the
moon this would be the track for you but
we shouldn't note that this is one of
the hardest careers to break into it
simply because it's so abstract and
Broad virtually anyone can apply to this
role and to meet the minimum
qualifications but it's extremely
difficult to actually get an interview
and then convince the interviewer that
you're the right choice also a lot of
the products that you work on will be
experimental meaning that they'll be the
first to get cut during a recession but
if you're looking for a sort of
entrepreneurial leadership role this
would be the way to go
foreign
on to a strongly related but starkly
different roll-up we have at program
managers again while the title has the
word manager in it you probably won't be
managing people unless you're L7 or
Beyond in instead it your role would be
to manage programs your primary job as a
program manager would be to execute the
vision of the product manager if the
product manager was the CEO of a product
you would essentially be dc00 you would
need to ensure that products are
delivered on time and within budget for
example if the product manager wants a
search feature that can scale to 100
million users it will be your job to
make sure that the backend systems can
keep up in a cost-effective manner this
generally means working with software
engineers and solutions Architects to
create robust scalable programs
basically you would be responsible for
bringing together all of the details to
make the product manager's Vision a
reality there are two main types of
program managers which are just program
managers and Technical program managers
if you're looking into this roll up I
think you definitely want to go the
technical program manager or GPM route
not only does the technical router piece
of potentially more but it's much easier
to score one of these Scrolls if you do
indeed have the technical know-how one
option for TPMS is to become a software
engineering DPM but there are plenty of
GPM roles that don't require any
software engineering skills instead it
they require technical knowledge of a
cloud systems databases networks
Enterprise Solutions like sap Oracle
Salesforce and so on while it does take
time to learn these disciplines you
often become Irreplaceable within an
organization during a market downturner
it's easy for companies to slash
products and thoughts product managers
and regular program managers but it's
way more difficult to cut a technical
program manager who is responsible for
Google cloud or essential internal
software like sap s4hana so being a
technical program manager gives you a
solid mix of having technical skills
that are hard to replace but also not
having to do technical stuff all day if
you chose the regular program manager
about on the other hand you'd be doing
essentially the same thing except you
like won't be dealing with tech products
instead you'll probably be dealing with
the supply chain and marketing or UI for
example if you were a supply chain
program manager at Apple you may be
responsible for ensuring that enough
iPhones make their way to retail
locations in the southern part of the US
similarly if you were a UI program
manager you may be responsible for
testing various UI features and
delivering the most effective set of
features you should keep in mind though
that if you're targeting one of these
broader rules you'll likely be facing a
lot more competition simply because more
people will meet the requirements this
is yet another reason to go down the
technical route but in the end it's up
to you
foreign
we have my personal favorite which is
Solutions architect unlike program
manager and the product manager roles
that appeal to a broad range of people
solution architect roles are usually
extremely specific these roles are super
technical meaning that you can't be as
your way into any of these roles but
that's also the beauty of these roles
you'll only be competing with people who
also know the technical stuff but what
exactly does a Solutions architect even
do well one way to think about it is
that they're basically these software
Engineers of non-coding tasks for
example if you need a coding algorithm
you would contact a software engineer
but if you need to deploy that algorithm
onto the cloud at scale you would
contact a cloud Solutions architect
that's definitely an oversimplification
of the role and that there are some
solution Architects that need to know
coding but in general Solutions
Architects handle all of the
technological tasks that don't involve
coding this includes things such as
migrations deployments database
management Network management how to
infrastructure and ID security usually
you'll choose one sector to be an expert
in for example you can be an expert in
Cloud Solutions and to know that ins and
outs of AWS gcp and Azure or you can be
an expert in Enterprise Solutions and
know everything about Oracle sap and the
Salesforce given the technical nature of
the role job security is usually on par
with software Engineers if not even more
this is especially true if you
specialize in something like cyber
security just because the job requires a
bunch of technical knowledge it does not
mean that you'll be doing technical
stuff all day though much of the job has
to do with the conveying technical
information to non-technical people for
instance if you're an internal Solutions
architect you would likely need to work
with a bunch of internal technical
program managers and provide them with
the best back-end solutions for a given
product if you're in an external
Solutions architect go work with
Enterprise customers and help these
customers Implement your company
solutions to the best extent if you are
a Solutions architect at AWS for example
your job might be to keep Netflix happy
in terms of the back end this means
maximizing speed scalability and
reliability while minimizing costs and
the lag in terms of career trajectory
Solutions Architects don't quite make it
into the seven figures but that's simply
because there's not as many levels in
terms of the compensation at each level
though you basically get the same
compensation as a TPM for example an L7
Solutions architect at Google makes 535
while an L7 TPM at Google makes 527 also
if you're a star Solutions architect
you'll have an easy time switching to
senior TPM roles for example a
reasonable switch may be to go from
being an L7 Enterprise architect to
being the director of enterprise
resource planning which is basically an
L8 TPM role from there you can become a
managing director vice president senior
vice president and so on and so forth so
in the end if you're willing to do
technical stuff but don't necessarily
want to code it Solutions architect is
definitely the way to go
as you've probably noticed by now this
video was mainly focused at Tech roles
that don't require coding but these
companies also hire a bunch of non-tech
roles as well for example they need
accountants data scientists Park
designers business analysts recruiters
and so on and these companies pay well
for all of these roles for example an L6
Google recruiter earns a whopping at 335
thousand dollars per year with that
being said though in the end these
companies are tech companies meaning
that the people who are the most
valuable and the most influential will
be Tech workers this primarily consists
of software engineers and the people who
work directly around software Engineers
like product managers program managers
and solutions architects so if you want
to play an integral role at these
companies but not have to code it these
three choices are by far the best
options
if you're more of a business person and
want to create overarching goals and
divisions and then not really deal with
the technical stuff you might want to
look into product management if you're
comfortable dealing with some technical
stuff but still want to mainly focus on
the business side of things you probably
want to look into program management and
finally if you're super comfortable with
technical stuff but you just don't want
to do coding specifically your best bet
would be to become a Solutions architect
all of these roles are in high demand
and not just inside fanger but across
the entire job market in the Modern Age
virtually every company needs ID
Solutions and all of these roles are
essential in delivering such ID
Solutions so even if you aren't able to
crack into thing directly with one of
these career pads it's more than likely
that you'll be able to make it into a
background company like Cisco or Oracle
and from there if you're truly a star
performer it's just a matter of time
until you make it into a fan company if
that's your goal of course which role
sounds most appealing to you comment
that down below also drop a like if
you'd like to be paid a thing salary and
of course consider checking out our
Discord Community such as future video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions and logically answered
but until then I'm hurry and I'll see
you guys on the next one